ADAM CARPENTER: Hi, everybody.
My name is Adam Carpenter.
As you just heard
Audie talk about,
there's a lot of
ways developers are
considering diversifying
their revenue, be it
ads, IAP, subscriptions.
For those of you who are
already firmly invested
in the IAP space,
I'm going to try
to go a little bit deeper
and talk about some
of the signs and the
patterns that you
can see in your own data,
which can potentially
help you identify if
there's opportunities
to grow your business.
So one of the ways that I
always like to look and think
about the whole
notion of revenue
and how it all
interrelates is something
that we call the revenue
tree, or some people
call the revenue funnel.
This is kind of a
very important view,
because it shows how all
the core components fit
together and feed upwards to
generate the revenue that we
see on a daily basis.
And if you're not
familiar with this graph,
to get the top-level
metric, you'd
multiply the two below
it, except in the case
the dotted-line boxes, where
you'd add them together.
And now when I think about a
lot of the core monetization
metrics, generally speaking,
I like to divide them
into two different categories.
The first-- the daily
buyer percentage--
I always like to think of that
as the primary monetization
metric, since for thinking
about the effectiveness
and your ability to
monetize your users,
it's almost always
better to go for breadth.
It's significantly
safer to try and get $1
out of everybody versus being
overly reliant on your whales.
In contrast, I like to think
of average revenue per paying
user, average transaction value,
and transactions per buyer
as secondary
monetization metrics,
because while they're critically
important, what they really
measure is your ability to
extract value from users
who have already chosen to pay.
And one of the jokes I
used to kind of make,
when I was on the
developer side--
and I still kind of
make it at Google Play--
give me virtually any game.
Tell me to double average
revenue per paying user.
I can easily do that and tank
the business at the same time,
because it's always so easy
to squeeze players and squeeze
players, and you're lifting
up your average revenue
per paying user, but your
buyer conversion is plummeting.
And so in terms of
topics today, I'm
going to kind of walk
through the revenue tree.
And the first thing
I want to do is
take a look at
topline revenue health
and show you some
of the ways that I
like to monitor revenue
performance that help me
understand how a game is doing.
And then next,
we're going to take
a look at buyer percentage,
and in particular, talk
about some ways to think
about increasing the returning
buyers, and especially the
frequency at which users
are paying within a month.
And finally, we move on to talk
about the secondary metrics.
And they're-- I'm going to
primarily try to give you some
food for thought about some ways
that you can potentially change
your games that could help
improve the metrics in that
space.
So to kick off with
topline revenue.
One of the major ways that
we're always driving it,
and one of the major ways
that we're maximizing
our performance, LiveOps.
Most of you are already
probably doing it.
If not, you're probably
considering it.
It is such an integral part
of driving our businesses,
of stimulating demand,
but LiveOps isn't this one
monolithic thing.
And the way that I
like to think of it
is breaking it out into supply
side sales or demand side
events.
And I like this
notion because it
helps to think about the
balance between the two.
So supply side sales, that's the
injection of discounted assets
into the economy, the ways
that you can give users
additional value for each of
the dollars that they're paying.
In contrast, demand
side events, this
is when we're running the
tournaments, the weekend
challenges, the competitive
engagements-- all the ways
that we get players to
engage more significantly,
ideally draining down
their asset balance
and creating the greater
potential for those users
to pay.
And the interrelation
between the two
is critically important
in order to ensure
that you have a very balanced
and healthy game economy
and that your revenue
is ultimately stronger.
Here's a couple examples
of vastly different ways
that developers like
to run their LiveOps.
In the case of the blue line--
the one on the left--
this is a perfect example
of a developer who
likes to run the
occasional, roughly
once-per-month massive sale.
And what you can see is they
generate a significant amount
of revenue during that period.
But then on a normal
week-by-week basis,
you're seeing--
this is the start of a LiveOps--
revenue spikes, trends down--
that's the off day of the
week when it's not running--
and then it starts again.
And so you kind of have this
constant pattern on a week
by week basis.
The green one,
this is an example
of a developer who's
trying to run LiveOps
virtually every day.
They're balancing the supply
side and the demand side,
and what they're doing is
creating a much tighter band.
And it's a very
interesting perspective
and an interesting approach,
because what the developer is
fundamentally trying to ensure
is that every day is appealing.
Every single day
some of their users
are perceiving good
value in the game
in being willing to opening
up their wallets and paying.
And so a great way to
think about this is,
what's the right strategy?
What's the best strategy?
Unfortunately, I
can't really tell you
that one is inherently
better than the other.
It depends on your
development team--
what your skill sets
are, what your game is--
but one of the
strategies that you
can use to understand how
your LiveOps is performing
is a monitoring technique we
call the revenue heartbeat.
And what the revenue
heartbeat does,
in any given calendar
month, calculate
the minimum revenue day,
the maximum revenue day,
and the average
revenue for the month.
And then if you
plot it over time,
you get a visualization
like what you see here.
And ideally with the revenue
heartbeat, what we're really
trying to see is that
the min and the max,
they form a tight band
around the average,
that you don't see any
wild variations on a month
by month basis--
you don't see any
divergence-- and
that as your average
revenue is growing,
you're seeing that
the bands themselves,
they're not inherently
widening because this ensures
that you're stimulating the
right kind of demand on a day
by day basis, and that your
players are engaging heavily
and engaging consistently.
Some of the more negative
patterns that you would see,
these are shown here.
And I really like point A
as an example, because this
is a wonderful case of a game,
which in the month of March,
they actually ran
a massive sale,
but what that sale
resulted in was
a pretty significant hangover.
And so you can see the spike,
but then the min fell off,
and it actually resulted
in a drop in the average.
So while sales are
inherently good,
if you can't randomize
the amount of hangover--
the duration of it--
you can run into results like
this, where your revenue ends
up being net negative for
the month, when you compare
to the month before.
In contrast to that,
point B in June--
this is actually a great
example of a developer
who began tightening
up their economy
during that particular month.
They didn't run as
many sales, but they
were stimulated into demand.
And what that was very
effective at doing
was getting users to drain
their asset balance down,
so there was more
of the need to pay.
Because as we all
know, for IAP games,
if a user's asset
balance is high,
what's the point of
spending any money?
But then you always
run into situations
like you see with point C here.
Massive Black Friday
sale, not enough
demand afterwards, so
you see a big spike,
but the min fell off again.
So this revenue heartbeat,
it's a really wonderful way
that you can actually
monitor and understand
the performance of
your game, and get
a good sense of the
effectiveness of the sales
that you're running, and whether
you're running potentially
too frequently.
There's also some
more advanced ways
that you can take a
look at your revenue.
And one of the ones
that I particularly like
is calculating the
coefficient of variation
for your daily revenue
across a month.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with this calculation,
what it is is take all the
daily revenue within a month,
calculate the standard
deviation of it,
and divide it by the mean.
What that will give
you is a measure
of the variability,
or volatility,
of your revenue in the month.
You can effectively think
of it as a percentage score.
And so it's really
useful for quantifying
LiveOps performance.
And additionally,
what we've actually
found is that
coefficient of variation,
it actually correlates
to revenue growth.
And so what I'm going
to talk you through now
is how you can actually use
this to understand the potential
for your games to
grow month over month,
and the kind of
optimizations and the values
that you should be looking for.
This particular graph--
and I'll explain it--
this is looking
at the top 250 IAP
games between January
2017 and January 2018.
And what we've done is looked at
their coefficient of variation
by month, and we've put
them all into buckets.
And so what you can largely see
is that a majority of the games
had a coefficient of
variation below 39%.
So there was some volatility.
But there wasn't
an extreme amount.
Where it gets really
interesting is
we take coefficient
of variation,
and we look at
which of these games
had month over month growth.
That's what we see here.
The games with the lowest
coefficient of variations
were much more likely to see
month over month growth--
games with a coefficient of
variation between 10% and 19%.
So a month over month growth
about 56% of the time.
In contrast, games with
a very high volatility,
they saw month over month growth
less than half of the time.
So it's kind of an
important thing to consider.
How volatile is the
revenue in your game?
How volatile are the sales?
And is it actually going
to be healthy for you?
And is there an opportunity to
try and optimize your LiveOps
cadence, balance the demand
and supply side events,
and decrease that volatility.
Because at the end of
the day, volatility
is not the ideal scenario
that we're looking for.
Consider a game where you're
running regular weekly sales
and events, or you're running
a major tentpole of sales
at the beginning of the month.
How easy is it for your
users to figure out
what their pattern is,
and then figure out that,
well, they always
run a major sale
at the beginning of the month.
Why should I ever spend
money any other time?
And as soon as you
start to create
that habit, the expectation,
the anticipation of your users
about when the sales and the
events are going to occur,
this is when you can start
getting into asset hoarding
situations, because users
know when the sale is.
They spend as much
money as they possibly
can afford during that sale, and
then they ride those discounted
assets for as long as possible.
This results in things
like spend cannibalization,
because users aren't going to
spend right before the sale,
because they know it's coming.
And all of these
combined, this is
what gives us the revenue
hangovers, that once players
have figured out the pattern,
you're actually losing money
when you've run your
sale and the hangover
you see afterwards.
So one of the ideas we
always like to talk about--
and I'd really encourage you
guys to think about this--
it's what I call predictable
unpredictability.
And what I mean
by that is can you
create scenarios and
situations in your game
where users log in expecting
something good to happen,
but they have no idea
what that good thing is?
Can you get your users to
anticipate a good thing,
but they're not going
to fundamentally change
their behavior before
it actually occurs?
It's a pattern you used
to use very effectively
on the developer side, and I'd
encourage you to think about
how predictable is your
game in terms of the events,
and is there an opportunity
to spice that up, and make it
so that players are
not fundamentally
changing their behavior because
they know what you're doing?
So moving on from that,
I want talk a little bit
about increasing your
returning buyers,
and I want to talk a lot
about the 80-20 rule.
How many of you guys are
familiar with this in games?
OK.
A few of you.
What the rule-- it's almost
like an industry meme-- says
is in a calendar month,
the top 20% of payers
contribute 80% of the revenue.
And when we look at
the Google Play data,
it's actually largely
true when you look
across the entire ecosystem.
The top 20% of payers pretty
much contribute about 80%
of the revenue, when you look
across each and every game.
But I've always kind of
thought like, it doesn't
seem inherently healthy.
It doesn't seem like it's
long term sustainable,
and it probably doesn't seem
like what the best performing
games out there are doing.
And in fact, they're
actually not.
This is the top 25 games on
Google Play during the month
of April, and what
we can actually see,
only six of these guys got
more than 80% of their revenue
from the top 20% of payers.
The majority of them,
they're in the low 70s.
Three of them were in the 60s.
Two of the games in the top 25
they were actually in the 50s,
so that the top 20%
of their players
only contributed about
53, 55% of their revenue.
These top games
are getting money
from a much more diverse
range of players.
And I really want to kind of
drive that home, because what
we're looking at here--
this is the top 100 games
in the month of April--
and what you can actually
see, as it rises,
the further down the
top chart you go,
the more reliant these games
are on their top 20% of payers.
It's kind of important
to think about.
And think about where does your
game fall into the top charts,
and how reliant are you
on your top payers, and is
there an opportunity to
actually broaden your base?
Because I really think
this is a key concept--
that the leading games on Play--
they've got the most
distributed revenue.
And so how can you take
that as inspiration
and figure out opportunities
for improving and optimizing
your games?
One of the ways that I
actually like to look at it
is taking monthly ARPPU,
average revenue per paying user,
and the number of unique days
users are paying in a month.
And what I like to do
is slice into deciles,
and for anybody who's not
familiar with what a decile is,
effectively, we take all
the payers in a month,
we put them into 10 buckets.
People who paid the most
go in the first bucket,
people who paid the second
most go in the second bucket,
and so on.
And what I'm going to talk
through in these slides,
this is an example of a
fairly typical action RPG.
And what you can see
is the top decile--
the people who paid the most--
$579 on average in a month.
It's a pretty good amount.
And the second best decile?
$120 a month.
And so this is kind of
falling into that 80-20 rule--
this example game.
Most of their revenue is coming
from the highest-paying users.
But what about
all of these guys?
50% of the monthly buyers
in this example game--
and this isn't a
contrived example--
this is a real example--
paid less than $10.
Is that an opportunity
for growth,
or is that just something
we don't care about,
because we only care about
the highest value users?
To me, because I'm like the
ultimate growth mindset person,
I think it's a real
opportunity, and in particular,
if we actually take a look
at the number of unique days
all of these monthly
buyers paid, half of them
only paid on one single day.
How easy would it be to get
these guys and gals to pay just
one extra day out of the month?
It doesn't seem like
it'd be that hard to me
to provide them with the
right compelling value
proposition which
incentivizes them to open up
their wallets a second day.
And actually what we've seen
when we look across virtually
every game-- and I'd really
encourage you guys to check
this yourselves--
for most of the games--
most of the IAP games,
somewhere between 40% and
60% of your monthly buyers
are only going to
pay on one day.
And so what's kind of the
real opportunity here?
What should we be focusing
on, and where can we extract
potentially the most value?
In my mind, it's
taking a really focus
on those users who are
only paying on one day--
and again, with
this example game,
what we see is 80%
of these buyers who
only paid on one day--
they paid less than $10.
So this, to me, is
just this huge upside
and this huge opportunity
to go after these users
with very targeted offers,
very targeted sales,
an exceptional, compelling
value proposition,
and get them to open
up their wallets,
because if your game had 50%
of the buyers who only paid
on one day, and 80% of
them paid less than $10,
think about if you can convert
half of them to paying another
$5, another $2, another $10.
That seems like a
huge upside to me.
And it's one of the
great things because it's
really, really sustainable.
And so what I'd
really encourage you
to do in terms of
improving performances,
think about that
value proposition.
Think about how you're
communicating the value
for money to your users.
How compelling is
it, how easy is
it for your users to understand
what they're actually getting?
I'd also encourage you to think
about your sales segmentation,
and especially how you're
presenting it to users.
One of the things I've
often seen in games,
and I've often wondered about
this from a user psychology
perspective, if I'm a low-value
user who occasionally spends
$5, and a game
runs a major sale,
and I see a $100
skew in the game,
am I going to be excited about
the $5 offer you're giving me,
or am I going to be upset seeing
the major value proposition
given to high spenders?
And I'm not even
going to spend my
five, because I know
that my five won't
let me compete with the guys
who are spending a hundred.
So think about how you're
segmenting your users,
and how you're
presenting those offers,
and try to give
users offers that
are targeted to their
personal spending habits
and strongly appeal to them.
Another one I want to get you
to think about his daily deals.
And these are becoming
a lot more popular.
But if you think about
some of the top games that
are doing them, are they really
communicating value well?
Are they communicating the
concept of scarcity well?
And are they really
communicating
almost like aspirational goals
for making that purchase?
Because I think that the
notion of daily deals
is extremely effective,
but I'd encourage
you guys to try and up-level it.
And the last one I'd
encourage you to think about
is this notion of a
repeat buyer's bonus.
What can you effectively
create which motivates users
to spend every single week?
And I'll throw out one that
I've been rolling around.
What if your game--
assuming, let's say you have
a game that has XP in it.
What if you created, let's say,
a 10% XP bonus for anyone who
purchases during the week?
So if you purchase
any amount of money--
$1 even-- you get a 10% bonus
for the next seven days.
Is that really going to
hurt your game economy,
or is that going to create a
compelling reason for users
to purchase at any price
point every single week?
I think it's the
latter, because I
think that's an extremely
appealing benefit that users
would get, plus, of course, the
IAP that they'd be purchasing.
And now, the last thing
I want to talk about
is optimizing secondary
metrics in here.
I'm not going to have
any strong advice.
This is more of a
food-for-thought thing,
because I do think there's some
opportunities for us to improve
our secondary metrics.
And where I want to start off is
kind of looking at core metrics
for--
like kind of the percentiles
for the secondary metrics
across Google Play.
And if we look at
transactions per buyer--
and this is across the
top 250 IAP games--
we see that on any given day,
a user who purchases makes
somewhere between 1.5
and 1.9 transactions,
and they're doing so at a
price point of $8.50 to $25.
And ultimately what this results
in is an average revenue per
paying user,
depending on the game,
of somewhere between
$13.70 and $44.50.
That's a pretty
significant amount.
But oftentimes it's coming
from a very small set of users.
And so I think it's something
important to consider
is, what's the relationship
between all of these metrics,
and is there opportunities
for improvement?
When we take a look at
how average transaction
value on the x-axis compares to
average revenue per paying user
on the y-axis, it's positive.
It's linear.
If you can get users to purchase
at a higher price point,
you're going to get more
revenue out of them--
obviously, that one.
But I think the
key thing here is
that given that the transactions
per buyer on a daily basis
were only 1.5 to 1.9.
The primary driver for average
revenue per paying user,
it's coming from that
average transaction value.
In contrast, when
we plot transactions
per buyer on the x-axis,
an average revenue
per paying user on the
y-axis is kind of just noise.
We actually spent
a decent amount
of time looking at cluster
analysis, curve fitting,
and other options like that.
We could not figure out
any reliable pattern
to predict what
was going on here.
And so this is one
of these areas where
I think it's actually more tied
to a game's design and a game's
core economy.
And then with one of the things
I'm starting to think about
is, how can we actually
leverage game design
to bring more order to the
chaos that is this relationship?
Game design has always
been one of my big things.
And if you go way
back, I was actually
a systems designer for years.
And game economies are
one of my other loves.
And it's always
figuring out, how
do you create the right
appeal in your players?
How do you incentivize the
right kind of sink rates?
And what are the improvement
things that we can do?
Because if you think about
that transactions per buyer--
and I encourage you to think
about this from the perspective
of your own game.
Where do you fall
in this spectrum?
Are you below the
25th percentile,
and if you are below
the 25th percentile,
how many assets are you
selling in your game?
Do you only sell gems,
or only sell coins,
or only sell credits?
And if you do, what
kind of price points
are you actually selling it at?
Because what I want
you to consider
is that if you have a low number
of transactions per buyer,
and you're seeing a lot of them
being sold at very high price
points, what's going to be
that velocity per money,
or have you effectively created
a scenario where users are
incentivized to buy the
largest pack possible because
of the bonuses that
are on top of them,
and then they ride those
assets for as long as possible?
Because users know that they're
going to spend them eventually,
so there's no urgency to
buy on multiple times.
In contrast, if you're
above the 75th percentile,
I think the first question
to ask is, how many assets
are you selling?
If you're selling two or more,
I think it's perfectly fine.
I think you're in a
really healthy range.
If you're only selling
one kind of asset,
what impulse-buying
decision making
are you actually
creating in your game?
Have you created a scenario
where users are incentivized
to make a small number
or a large number of very
small transactions each day--
$2, $2, $2.
If you are, I think
there's a risk that you're
leaving some money on the
table, because every time a user
has to make a decision
about making a purchase,
there's a chance
that they'll stop.
And so if you do
have a case where
a large number of transactions
are at very small price points,
think about whether
there's an opportunity
to upsell your users.
Instead of showing them
$2 for x number of gems,
give them a $2 offer and
give them a $5 offer.
Present them with two choices,
and see if you can upsell them.
Because at the end
of the day, I really
do think that there's
some opportunities
to optimize and
improve this area,
but it's fundamentally
going to come down
to you guys, the developers,
because each set of games
is different.
And so what I ask
you to encourage
you to do is go back to
your development teams
and ask questions like,
what's your velocity of money?
How many impulse
purchases are players
making on each and every day?
Does your end game
incentivize asset hoarding?
And in particular, how's
your game economy designed?
Is it a capex economy,
where users are primarily
purchasing assets--
purchasing, let's say, gems--
and spending them to
get permanent upgrades?
Or is it more a case that
users are purchasing some sort
of a consumable asset--
coins, credits--
and they're spending them
as part of their daily play?
And now, this is
kind of like one
of my views in terms
of growth, in terms
of how we build our business
and talk through all three
of these areas.
So just in the last
couple minutes,
I want to give you what I
see as the key takeaways I'm
hoping you'll take with you.
Minimize volatility,
because that's
going to be the biggest
driver for revenue growth.
Figure out how your
LiveOps is performing,
how you're balancing your
supply and demand side events,
and see if you can actually
close that volatility,
because what we've seen
from the top games on Play,
the lower the daily volatility,
the more likely games
are to see month
over month growth.
I also want you to consider
what's the 80-20 rule
look like in your game?
How much revenue are the top
20% of your payers contributing,
and is there an opportunity
to diversify and broaden
your base to get users who
are only spending once per day
or once per month to spend
a second time per month?
Because what we've seen from
the top 25 games on Play,
they're significantly less
reliant on their whales
than other games that are
further down the top charts.
And finally, just think
about your secondary metrics,
because we see that average
transaction value and average
revenue per paying user--
there's a strong correlation,
but there's not much
of a correlation-- no
correlation at all--
between transactions per buyer.
And I don't have a
solution for this one,
but I think with all the
creative minds that are out
in the audience in all
of your creative teams,
I think one of you guys,
or many of you guys,
can figure out a way to actually
improve this and optimize it
to better grow your business.
So, I hope you guys got some
benefit out of this today.
I really appreciate
your time here.
[APPLAUSE]